leute was geht ab hier ist ghani und
heute gibt's ein paar unten
kriegsbeginns hier auf dem kanal von
meinem bruder sk und ich starrte ihn
direkt games nur rausgekommen auf den
punkt net eigentlich ist der schnee muss
durch von heavy war und so aber den gibt
es jetzt auch zu spielen hathaway ist ja
sowieso schon eine ganze weile dauern ja
heute für pixel sg und das spiel macht
auf jeden fall ziemlich spaß und ich
spiele das so ein bisschen auf starts
aber funktioniert nicht so ganz gut weil
irgendwie wissen die leute immer wenn
man isst und tanz horst und das ist
uncool und da kann man halt nicht so die
super ist die superstarke ziehen wir
brauchen irgendwie so ein undercover
account oder so hat er jetzt auch so
gemacht und ja all diese sachen
wir setzen uns jetzt einmal komplett
durch weil der daten hartenstein stadt
ihre beiden steinfurt gut ich dürfte
beide kriegen endlich perfekt
jetzt schauen dass ich nicht abgestaubt
werden nachdem ich selbst abgeschafft so
ein bisschen bisschen viel
so ist das spiel man muss halt wirklich
hier aufpassen wie man irgendwie
durchkommt weil es so viele so viele
gegenspieler gibt und jeder kriegt gute
sachen
und da ist es halt ja wie gesagt relativ
schwer dass man da irgendwie ein
bisschen was reizt aber ich gebe mein
bestes und eisen schwert wenn mich nicht
alles täuscht
und da kommt nichts da kommt er nicht in
unser tod des autors arthur ist unser
tod wir sind alte regierung geschafft
krasse sache gezeigt ein bisschen
paranoia hat irgendwas gutes nee dann
lass mich in ruhe
das hat die sache weil bei dem spiel das
man nie wirklich
die chance hat weltkrieg seien sehr sehr
kurz sein und dann wird man irgendwie
alle zwei sekunden angegriffen wenn es
gerade nicht braucht naja von island auf
jeden fall hier kann man sogar sogar
eisenguss die abos platten kriegen
das ist ja alter das ähnlich gesehen
das ist ja im normalerweise geht es hier
nicht kreativ der zum beispiel hat einen
gehen wir jetzt erst mal probieren zu
töten weil wir wollen natürlich seine
brusttasche und das team erstmals wieder
wie nach einer bestimmten zeit gestartet
und nicht irgendwie nur noch ein paar
leute leben nach einer festen zeit und
deshalb kann es auch sein dass man mal
mit irgendwie fünf leuten oder sowas im
deathmatch steht wenn man irgendwie ein
bisschen eine lustige runde erwischt hat
und dann kommt kommt auch mal so was aus
aber ich verkaufe komplett
erstmal flugmodus nicht dass du mein
handy rum stadt der liebe contractors
hat mir gerade etwas geschickt
durchsetzte stones mein freund deaf
deaf.de
die frauen gibt down was ansicht dass
man ihn nicht treffen kann mit file oder
so alter schwede gleich alter der muss
jetzt mal daumen sein dankeschön so ich
will einfach nicht sein ding schnell auf
ok kommen also schnecke okay das war
runde eins direkt in die nächste
ich hoffe mal dass mein mikrofon ich
wiederum stark dass in letzter zeit
recht komplett zufällig ob das gerade am
ausrasten ist oder nicht
was schreibt ok wichtige sachen eine
freunde die aber noch top secret sind
und auf dem kanal von mein guter weg
saison nichts geheimnis verraten wenn
dann auf meinen kann abonniert die
endlos menschen
wir können wir noch mal gewinnen die
runde die letzte war auf jeden fall
wirklich gut für die dior die karte hast
dich über alles
die karte hasste ich weil ich habe ich
schon so oft am anfang nichts gekriegt
also jetzt sieht es der diskonter
natürlich ganz viel versprechend aus
weil wir ganz guten punkt erwischt haben
wir trotzdem trat schon wieder kein
schwert und und schwert ist es natürlich
relativ schwer das zu reißen in survival
games auf diese weise games sind oder
normalen okay wir haben wir schon
verloren wenn man okay das play crafter
herzlichen glückwunsch
der typ ist zwar nicht besonders gut
besonders oft einfach nur unheimlich
viel
aber wem verkauft ja und die sind schön
am team oder was gut bei euch auch kaum
juckt mich nicht ich kriege euch alle
ich habe einfach ein schwert abgestaubt
ich habe mit ich habe ein schwert
abgestorben ist jetzt habe ich die
chance mich hat einfach nichts weil man
diese erst mal das alte wasser aus dem
senegal aktion ich darf mir so komme ich
gerne mit der hand drauf habt solltet
niemand mit der hand aber ich habe hier
die karten ab geschockt so fleck rafter
den klatschen erst mal dafür dass ihr
hier den kriterien bassist der sucht das
spiel auch schon wieder enorm sub dass
das war okay dann wird es abschreiben
wollen
der andere mit abstimmen wollen sicher
sollte denn der fliehkräfte nicht
erklärten schade gg auf jeden fall gehen
wir raus in die nächste runde
er ist auf jeden fall nicht schlecht
dass katzen vermisst aber er zog kraft
viel also man sieht ihn so oft in
irgendwelchen runden
man muss ja auch viel zocken wollen auf
platz eins sein will und als wir das
jetzt auch auf platz eins sein möchte
hier in gescher scale-out schnittstelle
raus wird wahrscheinlich auch hier auf
platz eins sein wollen aber es gibt
definitiv bessere spieler hier im player
spiel
wird den drei mal in der luft zerfetzt
denke ich mal
haupt behaupte ich mal ganz frech in
flake kreft aber auch selber wäre das
aber auch ein kleiner sucht die der wehr
ii um er hat noch nicht mal das schwert
eben schnell rein
gut wir haben kein gutes equipment das
was wert sammelst du zunächst wird man
was man kriegen kann
weil was schlechter aus als heute gibt
es gar nicht glaube ich hier wirklich
nicht alles täuscht weil ich einfach
bord alte luft combo des todes nein ganz
cool wenn leute so die mich abonniert
haben ein bisschen pvp sehen wollen dann
können sie auch von meinem bruder gucken
im moment weil ja nicht attraktiv weil
er wie ihr vielleicht wisst oder nicht
schon mal erzählt habe probleme mit
seinem laptop bgld geht im moment nicht
und deshalb spur
deshalb zog ich ein bisschen papier war
es schon so kommt heran
ok davon das war ziemlich gut
ausgelastet aber dann hätte ich mir
nicht gönnen können wenn wir den kriegen
dass ich gut
wobei ich das kriegen wir kriegen
es ist ein assist seinen ex club das
sehr schön läuft auf jeden fall auch bei
ihm aber wir sind schon wieder fallen
das ist immer relativ viel versprechend
finde ich einmal verlieren dann hat man
die runde schon so viel gewonnen hat er
gar keinen brustpanzer nicht dir bewusst
zurück er sieht bei dem texture pack
leider relativ gleich aus er hat auf
jeden fall bewusst so gut tut gut
dankeschön
das war zwar sozial aber muss auch mal
seine freundin wenn man hier was reißen
möchte in dem spielen sollen schön ruhe
lassen habe ich sagen ja auch weil ja es
ist gut
immer diese menschen die kommen an hauen
ab und kommt hier an
so gut die runde ist eigentlich relativ
dürfte relativ neues werden wenn das
werk kassel die noch auf der karte
gewinnen will jetzt hier heißt immer
auch ein erlebt noch aber ich weiß echt
nicht wurde es macht auf jeden fall
fahren wir hier durchmarschieren
welche filme mit meinem zettel icon dass
die leute mal vorbeikommen weil es
gerade gut es geht
ich frag mich nur wo der andere sich der
tvb straight inhalt schreiben ist ist
natürlich das beste was das beste was
man machen kann wenn man so eine gute
internet leitung hat einfach nicht herum
nicht nicht jumpen nicht rumspringen
sondern einfach außen rum laufen und die
hocke gehen nochmal hätten die nächste
runde eine geht auf jeden fall noch ich
nehme umbenennen dass die leute nicht
direkt auf mich gehen
die karte hat mir drei unterschiedliche
karten jetzt hier gute aufnahme auf
jeden fall die mich wirklich auf meinen
kanal bringen und vielleicht gewinnen
sie jetzt noch mal
man weiß es ja nicht und ich gehe mal
dass mein bruder
wenn er wieder zocken kann das glück es
gehe auch sehr gefallen nur auf sehr
gefallen wird kann ich mir zumindest
vorstellen
alles klar als er die sache jetzt ist
man muss man muss eigentlich am anfang
gute sachen kriegen und dann muss man
drauf gehen auf die leute weil wenn man
es anders macht dann hat man eigentlich
schon so gut wie verloren
gucken wir mal guck mal das ist auf
jeden fall gut für meine karriere hier
ein bisschen aufsteigen den start wenn
jetzt noch einer kommt wahrscheinlich
down so passen wir die mal ein bisschen
auf
da werde ich mal reinschauen
da war ich noch nie in meinem ganzen
leben habe ich gerade eine axt im
inventar gab es wird mich auf jeden fall
wundern
ich darf nämlich gelb kein oder sich
schön aus auf jeden fall ein bisschen
start am start
man wird dann immer raus getrieben
nachteil den bogen habe ich noch nicht
ist das gut
was ist das denn jetzt wie hat der uns
der winter grad eben geboxt
diese hey es geht auch gar nicht immer
hat die überhaupt nicht gesehen den
typen noch weiter okay das ist jetzt ich
habe dafür die fahrer neuer warten sie
bis runter gezeigt das ist der dass der
freaky friday star
oh gott ich bin so gut wie tot
schade na gut man kann natürlich jeder
um gewinnen deshalb will ich sagen meine
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
lasst man leichter ich hoffe mein bruder
kann bald auch wieder selbst videos
machen damit ich nicht mehr machen muss
ein spaß macht auf ihren top box ursache
sondern weil ihr wisst schon viel spaß
beim nächsten video das ihr euch jetzt
ankommen werde
und das war eine sehr kreative
verabschieden